helping with the anxiety of illness or
the tragedy
of bereavement and i'm deeply sorry to
say
that the number of people has been that
have been taken from us
has surpassed a hundred thousand as the
house was discussing
uh only an hour or so ago and i know
that the house will join me
in offering condolences to all those
who have lost loved ones the most
important thing
we can do to honor their memory is to
persevere
against this virus with ever greater
resolve and that's why we've launched
the biggest vaccination program
in british history three weeks ago i
reported that the uk had immunized 1.3
million people
now that figure has multiplied more than
fivefold to exceed
6.8 million people more than any other
country
in europe and over 13 of the entire
adult
population in england we've now
delivered first doses to over
four-fifths
of those aged 80 or over and over half
of those aged between 75
and 79 and three quarters of elderly
care home
residents and though it remains an
exacting target we are on track
to achieve our goal of offering a first
dose to everyone
in the top four priority groups by the
middle of february
i can also reassure the house that all
current evidence
shows that both the vaccines we are
administering
remain effective against the new variant
that was first identified in london
and the south east by means of our world
leading capability
in genomic sequencing the uk has now
sequenced
over half of all covid19 viral genomes
that have been submitted to the global
database 10 times more
than any other country and yesterday my
right honourable friend the health
secretary
announced our new variant assessment
platform through which we will work
with the world health organization to
offer our expertise
to help other countries because a new
variant
anywhere poses a potential threat
everywhere to guard against this danger
we must also take
additional steps to strengthen our
borders to stop those strains
from entering the uk we've already
temporarily closed all travel corridors
and we're already requiring anyone
coming into this country
to have proof of a negative covered test
taken in the 72 hours before leaving
they must also complete a passenger
locator form which must be checked
before
they board and then quarantine on
arrival for 10 days
i want to make clear that under the
stay-at-home regulations it is
illegal to leave home to travel
abroad for leisure purposes
and we will enforce this at ports
at airports by asking people why they
are leaving and instructing them
to return home if they do not have a
valid reason
to travel we have also banned all travel
from 22 countries where there is a risk
of known variants
including south africa portugal and
south american
nations and in order to reduce the risk
posed by uk nationals and residents
returning home from these countries
i can announce that we will require all
such arrivals who cannot be refused
entry to isolate in government provided
accommodation
such as hotels for 10 days without
exception
they will be met at the airport and
transported directly
into quarantine the department for
health and social care
is working to establish these facilities
as quickly as possible
and my right honourable friend the home
secretary will set out the details
of our plans in her statement shortly
my right-hand friend the chancellor of
the duchy of lancaster has this morning
spoken to the first ministers of
scotland and wales
and the first and deputy first ministers
of northern ireland
and as we have throughout this pandemic
we will be working closely with the das
to implement
these new measures so that where
possible we continue with a uk-wide
approach mr speaker it was the emergence
of a new variant up to 70
more transmissible that forced england
back into lockdown
and i know everyone yearns to know how
much longer we must endure
these restrictions with all their
consequences for jobs livelihoods
and most tragically of all the life
chances of our children
we will not persist for a day longer
than is necessary
but nor can we relax too soon because if
we do
we run the risk of our nhs coming under
still greater pressure
compelling us to reimpose every
restriction
and sustain those restrictions for
longer
so far our efforts do appear to have
reduced
the r rate but we do not yet have enough
data to know exactly how soon
it will be safe to reopen our society
and economy at this point
we don't have enough data to judge the
full effect
of vaccines in blocking transmission
nor the extent and speed with which the
vaccines will reduce
hospitalizations and deaths nor how
quickly
the combination of vaccinations and the
lockdown can be expected to ease the
pressure
on the nhs what we do know
is that we remain in a perilous
situation
with more than thirty seven thousand
patients now in hospital with kovid
almost double the peak of the first wave
but the overall picture
should be clearer by mid-february by
then
we will know much more about the effect
of vaccines
in preventing hospitalizations and
deaths
using data from the uk but also other
nations like israel
we will know how successful the current
restrictions have been
in driving down infections we will also
know how many people are still in
hospital with kovid
which we simply can't predict with
certainty
today so we will then be in a better
position to chart a course
out of lockdown without risking a
further surge
that would overwhelm the nhs
when i announce the lockdown i said we
would review its measures in
mid-february
once the most vulnerable have been
offered the first dose
of the vaccine so i can tell the house
that when parliament returns from recess
in the week commencing
the 22nd of february subject to the full
agreement
of the house mr speaker we intend to set
out the results of that review
and publish our plan for taking the
country
out of lockdown that plan will of course
depend on the continued success of our
vaccination program
the capacity of the nhs and on deaths
falling at the pace we would expect
as more people are inoculated
our aim will be to set out a gradual and
phased approach
towards easing the restrictions in a
sustainable way
guided by the principles we've observed
throughout the pandemic
beginning with the most important
principle of all that reopening
schools must be our national priority
and the first sign of normality
beginning to return
should be pupils going back to their
classrooms
i know how parents and teachers need as
much certainty
as possible including two weeks
notice of the return of face-to-face
teaching
so i must inform the house that for the
reasons i have outlined it will not be
possible
to reopen schools immediately after the
february half term
and i know how frustrating that will be
and will be
for pupils and teachers who want nothing
more
than to get back to the classroom and
for parents and for carers
who spent so many months juggling their
day jobs
not only with with home schooling but
with meeting the
the myriad other demands of their
children from breakfast
until bedtime and i know to the worries
we all share
about the mental health of our young
people during this prolonged period
of being stuck at home so our plan for
leaving the lockdown
will set out our approach towards
reopening
schools if we achieve our target
of vaccinating everyone in the foremost
vulnerable groups with their first
dose by the 15th of february and
every passing day sees more progress
towards that goal
then those groups that have developed
immunity from the virus
about three weeks later that is by
the 8th of march
we hope it will therefore be safe to
begin the reopening of schools
from monday the 8th of march with other
economic and social restrictions being
removed
thereafter as and when the data permits
then or thereafter i should say mr
speaker
as we're extending the period of remote
learning beyond the middle of february
i can confirm that the government will
prolong arrangements for providing free
school meals
for those eligible children not in
school including food parcels and the
national voucher scheme
until they've returned to the classroom
we can also commit now that as we did
this financial year
we will provide a program of catch up
over the next
financial year and this will involve a
further 300 million pounds of new money
to schools for tutoring and we work in
collaboration with the education sector
to develop as appropriate specific
initiatives
for summer schools and a coveted premium
to support catcher but we recognize that
these
extended school closures
have had a huge impact on children's
learning
which will take more than a year to make
up
so we will work with parents teachers
and schools
to develop a long-term plan to make sure
pupils have the chance
to make up their learning over the
course of this parliament
i know mr speaker that the measures i'm
setting out today will be deeply
frustrating to many honorable friends
and colleagues and disappointing
for all of us but the way forward
has been clear ever since the vaccines
arrived and
as we inoculate more people hour
by hour this is the time to hold our
nerve in the endgame
of the battle against the virus and our
goal now
uh must be to buy the extra weeks we
need to immunize
the most vulnerable and get this virus
under control
so that together we can defeat this most
wretched
disease reclaim our lives once and for
all and mr speaker
i commend this statement to the house
yeah
yeah i'm now going to call the leader of
the opposition
kirsten who is participating virtually
kirsten
thank you mr speaker and can i thank the
prime minister for advanced site of his
statement mr speaker to lose a hundred
thousand people to this virus
is nothing short of a national tragedy
it is a stark number
an empty chair at the kitchen table
a person obviously taken before their
time
and today we should remember that
and we should mark the moment by
learning the lessons
of the last year to make sure that the
same mistakes
are not made again of course
any government would have struggled with
this pandemic
i get that the british people get that
but the reality is that britain is the
first country in europe to suffer a
hundred thousand deaths
and we have one of the highest death
rates in the world
and the prime minister often says that
he's been balancing the health
restrictions against
economic risks but that simply doesn't
wash
because alongside that high death toll
we also have we also have the deepest
recession of any major economy
the lowest growth of any major economy
and we're on course to have one of the
slowest recoveries
of any major economy so for all the
contrition and sympathy that the prime
minister expresses
and i recognize how heartfelt that is
the truth is this was not inevitable
it wasn't just bad luck
it's the result of a huge number of
mistakes by the prime minister
during the course of this pandemic we
were too slow into lockdown last march
too slow to get protective equipment to
the front
line and of course too slow to protect
our care homes mr speaker 20
of deaths in this pandemic have come
from care home residents 20
and i really don't think that the prime
minister
and the health secretary understand just
how offensive it was
to pretend that there was a protective
ring
around our care homes the government had
the chance over the summer to learn from
those mistakes in the first wave
and prepare for a second wave and a
challenging winter
i put that challenge to the prime
minister in june
but that chance was wasted the
government then went on to fail to
deliver an effective test trace and
isolate system
despite all of the warnings they failed
to deliver clear and reliable public
messaging
crucial in a pandemic one minute telling
people to go to work
then to do the complete opposite
and the prime minister has failed on a
number of occasions to follow the
scientific advice
that the virus was getting out of
control first in september
when that advice was given and the
failure to implement
a circuit break or lockdown over half
term as we suggested
then in december with the fiasco over
christmas mixing
and once again in the 13-day delay
from december 22nd when that further
medical advice was given and the third
national lockdown
was finally introduced as a result we've
seen
a third wave more deadly than the first
and second waves
mr speaker 50 000 people have died
since november the 11th
50 000 deaths in 77 days
that's a scarcely believable toll on the
british people
now in isolation any of these mistakes
are perhaps
understandable taken together
it's a damning indictment of how the
government has handled this pandemic
the prime minister says well now is not
the time to answer the question why
that's the answer he gave back in the
summer after the first wave that then
was not the time
to answer why he said the same after the
second wave
and he says it again now each time
repeating the mistakes
over and over again that's why now is
the time
to ask and answer the question why
the way out of this nightmare has now
been provided by our amazing scientists
our nhs our armed forces and hundreds of
thousands of volunteers
the vaccine program is making incredible
progress
the british people have come together to
deliver what is the largest peacetime
effort
in our history and despite the prime
minister's constant complaining
all of us all of us are doing whatever
we can
to help that vaccine roll out as swiftly
and as safely as possible
on schools first i have to say
even for this prime minister it's quite
something
to open schools one day close them the
next
to call them vectors of transmission
and then to challenge me to say that the
schools he's closed
are safe only now
to give a statement where he says that
schools can't open until the 8th of
march at the earliest
because it's not safe to do so
that's his analysis it's the sort of
nonsense that's led us to the highest
death
toll in europe and the worst recession
but of course we welcome any steps
forward in reopening schools
and we're going to look at the detail of
how the education secretary
plans to deliver this and the plans to
deliver online learning
and i also hope the prime minister will
take seriously our proposal
echoed incidentally by the children's
commissioner
and the conservative chair of the
education select committee
the once the first four categories of
the most vulnerable
have been vaccinated by mid-february
he should bring forward the vaccination
of key workers
and use that window of the february half
term to vaccinate all school staff
including every teacher and teaching
assistant there's a clear week there
uh when that could be done um and it
should be done
on borders we'll look at the details or
order order
i've got to say oh the right homogeneous
coming to the end is well past the five
minutes that's allocated
mr speaker on borders mr speaker we'll
look at the prime minister's
statement in detail i'd obviously hear
what the home secretary
um has to say um but mr speaker
you know in due course there will be a
public inquiry
um and the prime minister will have to
answer question
but i hope that we can finally answer
this very simple and direct question
because yesterday the prime minister was
maintaining the government had done
his words everything we could to save
lives
so is he really saying to those grieving
families
that their loss was just inevitable
and that none of the hundred thousand
deaths
could have been avoided thank you mr
speaker
prime minister terrible
uh well mr speaker if uh the right
honourable gentleman
asks about uh mistakes and i've said
there will be
a time uh to reflect and to analyze to
learn lessons and
and to prepare but i may say to him that
i believe the biggest mistake that uh
he has made is in seeking continually to
attack
uh what the government has been trying
to do at every opportunity
uh supporting one week and then
attacking the very same uh policy
uh the next week and uh he complains
about a confusion of messages mr speaker
how much has he actually done
as leader of the opposition uh to
reassure the public for instance about
nhs
test and trace which has done a very
good job i notice of
confining him uh for the third time uh
what has he done
to reassure people about messaging uh
rather than attacking
confusion and trying to so doubt about
what the government is doing i think
there was a very different path open to
him at the beginning of this
pandemic and i think it's a great pity
that he hasn't taken it
uh if i'm if i may say so on on schools
uh mr speaker
he knows perfectly well that the problem
is not that schools are
unsafe they are not unsafe schools are
safe
and he should say it and his union pay
masters should hear him say it
loud and clear the problem is that mr
speaker that they bring
communities together obviously a large
numbers of kids
are a uh considerable uh vector of of
transmission it's not that there's any
uh particular extra risk uh mr speaker
to
uh those involved in uh in education and
i i heard with interest
uh what he had to say about uh
his proposal for dive for changing
the jcvi priority
list and i really think that the right
honourable gentleman should reflect
on what he is saying because the jcvi
priority list
one to nine is designed by experts
by clinicians to prioritize mr speaker
those groups
who are most likely to die or to suffer
from coronavirus and by trying to change
that
and saying that uh he wants now to uh
bring in other
uh groups of of public sector workers to
be decided by politicians
rather than uh by the jcvi uh he has to
explain
uh which vaccines he would take from
which vulnerable groups
mr speaker to make sense of his policy
because that is what he is doing
and that is what the labor proposal
would involve and i and
indeed by making it more difficult
for us to vaccinate all those vulnerable
groups in the fastest
possible way mr speaker that policy
that labor policy would actually delay
our route
out of lockdown delay our ability to get
kids
back into school in the way that they
want so it's i i urge him
uh to think again or at least to explain
which members of those vulnerable groups
would be deprived
of vaccines in order uh to follow the
labor policy and
uh and all i can say mr speaker uh
having listened carefully to what
uh the honourable gentleman had to say
is that uh
everybody will have to answer questions
uh at the end of this
and i think all politicians let me put
it this way all politicians
will be asked what they did what we did
collaboratively working together
for the people of our country to beat
this virus
and i'm not sure that in uh upon
reflection
the unrivaled gentleman's choice uh was
the right one for either for his party
or the country
let's send to surrey to the chair of the
select committee
jeremy hunt thank you mr speaker on
monday baroness harding said that 40
percent of the people
asked to self-isolate my nhs test and
trace weren't
fully doing so which works out today a
worrying 30
000 people every single day who are
potentially still spreading the virus
many of them still
going to work um because this is such a
big threat to our containment strategy
for the virus
i wonder the prime minister could say
what he thinks we need to do
to deal with this and in particular
whether it is now time to consider
making a blanket offer to those
asked to self-isolate that we will make
good any salary
they lose because in the end that may be
cheaper
than having to extend furlough if the
case rate remains high
i very much respect uh my right normal
friend's
uh suggestion and uh uh and i understand
the logic of what he is saying
uh but i believe that the people of this
country uh should be
uh isolating self-isolating the way that
the railroad general leader of the
opposition
uh is rightly doing uh on the basis that
it's the right thing for themselves for
their families and for the country they
do get support
uh where needed of 500 pounds and there
are very
considerable fines for failing to do it
and i think that is the
the right way forward and i hope you
will uh join me in commending
uh prompt action by everybody who is
asked to self i say it's the right thing
to do
for you for your family and for the
country to scotland
to the leader of the snp in blackford
and thank you mr speaker and let me
thank the prime minister for advanced
copy of his statement
mr speaker as we know yesterday the uk
reached yet another terrible milestone
100
000 covered related deaths today
it is only right that we reflect on all
of those who have lost their
lives during this pandemic and our
thoughts and prayers are
most especially with their families
those who are left with the
heaviest burden of grief in time
there will be a reckoning on the uk
government's response to this virus
and it's clear that that verdict may
well be damning
in the here and now though it remains
our job to focus on how we can support
and save as many people as possible
in the weeks and months ahead that means
a renewed commitment to maintaining
public health
but it also must mean a renewed package
of financial support for all of those
all of those prime minister who've been
left behind by this tory government
right now covert is the immediate threat
to life but
poverty remains a coward too in 2019 the
ippr
revealed that tony austerity cuts over
the previous decades
had resulted in as many as 130 000
preventable deaths the prime minister
promised not to repeat tory austerity
if people were to believe him then he
should start by making three important
announcements today
extend the furlough scheme for the fuel
duration of the pandemic
maintain the uplift to universal credit
and apply it to legacy
benefits and put in place a package of
support
for the three million included prime
minister
11 hour announcements have got to stop
these decisions can't wait
until the budget in march people need
certainty now
i asked the prime minister these same
questions at prime minister's questions
but failed to get a straight answer
so please try again prime minister will
his government extend further
maintain the universal credit uplift and
offer support for the 3 million excluded
and finally mr speaker on international
travel
both the scottish and welsh governments
want to go further on quarantining
measures
than what his uk government is proposing
will the prime minister stop his half
measures
and enjoy the governments in scotland
and wales in stricter enforcement
on international travel that prime
minister
would be leadership
well mr speaker i look forward to what
the devolved administrations
uh do later uh but
uh i i can tell the house that we're
putting in the toughest
measures of virtually anywhere in the in
the world and the other and
my run-on friend the home secretary will
be uh setting out the detail
uh in in due course and i can tell him
that
the uh this country uh through the might
of the uk treasuries my brother befriend
the chancellor
has said many times has been able to
look after people across the uk
it's thanks to the uh the uk government
uh that we have
the furlough scheme the bounce back
loans the many other forms of
uh of support uh in its thanks to uh the
uk that we have
for instance the army uh able to move
people uh in distress with covid
uh in remote parts of of scotland uh to
uh to the hospitals where they need to
get to and indeed
the british army helping across uh
scotland mr speaker i'm proud
to say to distribute the vaccines uh
that
are so essential for our fight back from
this virus so i hope
uh that he will abandon uh his uh
nationalist position
a narrow nationalist position and
look at the uh the achievements of the
uk
overall and i think it is it is a a fine
fine thing be a wonderful thing by the
way
if the scottish nationalist party for a
moment uh would stop
talking about their desire uh for a
referendum mr speaker
while we are trying to deal with a
pandemic
david davis thank you mr deputy speaker
the the prime minister is very properly
concerned to
protect our national health service and
particularly to prevent hospitals and
intensive care units being overwhelmed
this winter
my question is about the scope to
enhance primary care
to reduce the need for cobit patients to
go to
hospital in first gear in the first
place new canadian studies
uh published this week four and a half
thousand people
show the use of culture scene has cut
hospital emissions by 25 percent
and death rates by almost half similarly
i have a mectin studies
some of them have shown 75 reductions in
in death rates
what scope is there to act quickly to
enhance our primary care level to
protect populations
and hospitals this winter this winter
not next week
i can tell my right honourable friend he
makes a very important point
and uh the therapeutics task force is
currently uh reviewing both
uh the drugs uh that he mentions i'll
make sure that he's kept
up to speed with their findings let's
head to
sir ed davey and davey
mr speaker as of 6 30 pm yesterday
the uk has the worst recorded death rate
by header population in the world
this is a grave moment for our country
i'm sure all our hearts go out to the
families
who have lost loved ones
last week the prime minister told me he
was still not prepared
to launch the inquiry into the kobe
crisis
that he promised six months ago
so instead today will he at least
tell the country that he will launch
this inquiry
sometime this year so we can find out
why our country has seen the worst death
rates from covert in the world
learn the lessons and give bereaved
families
the answers and the justice he
owes them
prime minister mr speaker once again the
uh
man deputy speaker uh madame deputy
speaker once again the
uh right honourable gentleman uh has the
answer contained in his uh question
because this country is
going through a very grievous bout
of uh a deadly pandemic
uh he rightly draws attention to the uh
to the death toll
uh of a hundred thousand and uh as he
knows there are currently thirty seven
thousand
uh people uh in hospital and the entire
british state is working flat out uh to
bring
uh that virus under control and to get
us through this
pandemic and out at the other side and
uh now as
as i've told him before not the right
time to consecrate the
uh energies and efforts of officialdom
uh
and uh it would be huge uh
to an inquiry though as i have said
before i said
last night and i'll reassure him again
today yes of course
there will be a time to learn lessons
uh to reflect uh and to understand
and to prepare madam deputy speaker
now we go to richard drax
thank you madam deputy speaker can i
welcome and
thank my writer and friend for his
upbeat statement which offers much
needed hope
to a beleaguered nation rather contrary
to captain hindsight's contribution
with the successful inoculation program
in full swing
his plan to break free from lockdowns
and restrictions
is critical variance or no variance
does my right on friend agree that the
lives and livelihoods of
millions of our citizens now depend
on a more proportionate response to this
pandemic
which will require political courage to
initiate
mr speaker i very much respect the point
of view of my
honorable friend who has long been
a keen and uh and justified campaigner
for
for liberty and i i share his instincts
very strongly
but i must tell him that we will be uh
we will continue to be cautious
uh in our approach because we do not
wish to see
more lives lost than we can possibly
avoid
uh mr speaker and so that's why what we
will do
is continue with the rollout of the
vaccine program the fastest in
uh in europe and uh currently uh
and uh on february the 15th as i
uh just said to the house uh we will
look at uh where we are we will be
setting out
a a road map which i hope uh will be
useful to him
and uh to all colleagues throughout the
house on february the 22nd
and now we go to jim shannon
thank you madam deputy speaker and thank
the prime minister
could or would the prime minister
confirm what discussions have taken
place with his counterparts in education
to give ample time for teachers to
either plan their online teaching with
special reference
to children who cannot or will not be
able to access their online classes
i agree with the prime minister i think
it's better that the children are back
in their in their classrooms
but can the prime minister ensure that
all the teaching staff
especially the special needs teachers
will be a priority for the vaccine rule
night
and can he also confirm that there will
be no shortage of vaccine
as was indicated on the press today
thank you
prime minister mr speaker madam speaker
forgive me
uh we will uh we're rolling out
um a 1.3 million uh laptops
uh we're making sure that uh kids
uh pupils have access to uh to online
learning wherever
uh wherever possible uh but the most
important thing
is as the the radar gentleman has
rightly said you get
kids back in uh school as soon as we as
we
sensibly can that's what this government
is uh determined
to do uh i i want to reassure him about
the the vaccination programmer he
mentioned anxieties about
uh supply as i stand before you today by
the deputy speaker
i'm confident that we'll deliver on the
february the 15th
pledge and that will be will continue uh
to be able to drive up i see my
uh honorable friend uh who the minister
for
uh for the vaccine rollout uh confirming
that we will be able to continue
that uh accelerating curve of supply as
well
christian wakefoot thank you madam
deputy speaker
i joined with members from across the
house in sending my deepest
of condolences to each and every one of
the individuals who's tragically
passed away as a result of covert
however during this extremely difficult
time i have nothing but admiration
for the army of volunteers working
tirelessly in my constituency and across
the country
will the prime minister join me in
thanking organizations like the fed
jewish volunteering network heads up and
porch boxers along with all those who've
done so much
to protect the vulnerable and the needy
impress which regular from whitefield
mr speaker i i will indeed join my
honourable friend in paying tribute to
those
uh volunteers in uh his constituency uh
they join a huge constellation of of
shining points of light across our
country it's been one of the most
extraordinary things
uh one of the uh the constellations one
of the few constellations of this
crisis has been the the upsurge uh
madame deputy speaker that has been
involuntary now we go to
debbie abrams thank you madam deputy
speaker
and can i also associate my remarks with
uh
with others and express my sincerest
condolences to everyone who's lost a
loved one and particularly the
constituents i spoke with last night
madam deputy speaker professor michael
marmot's recent report
pointed to four drivers which have
contributed to the high
and unequal death toll in the uk he
identified the
governance and political culture which
has damaged social cohesion include and
inclusivity
the widening inequalities in power money
and resources
their aggressive austerity policies over
the last 10 years
and the declining life expectancy and
health healthy life expectancy
of the poorest particularly women which
is amongst the worst
of all comparable economies
professor marmot has called for the
government to address this
these issues and to build back fairer
so will the prime minister and his
cabinet listen to him
i have a very high regard madam deputy
speaker for michael marmot and worked
uh closely with him uh for many years
and
uh i believe his advice is invaluable
and we will indeed be
making sure that as we come through this
pandemic uh we look at the way it is
impacted on the
the poorest and the most vulnerable and
indeed mrs uh madame baby speaker we
will
build back pharah and now
we go to
james stevenson thank you madam deputy
speaker
the vaccine rollout now offers hope and
relief to vulnerable people who have
spent
months living in fear and in isolation
to hear that 6.8 million vaccines have
now been delivered
is an amazing achievement and i thank
everyone involved in this rollout
the mass vaccination hubs are an
important part of the scheme
but many of my constituents with
mobility issues
are worried they're going to miss out on
their vaccine because they can't make
the journey to one of these larger hubs
could the prime minister give them
reassurance that they will be offered a
vaccine locally or even in their
own homes and anyone unable to travel
will be
fully supported the
honorable lady raises a very important
point and i hope she will give this
reassurance to
her constituents that uh they need to
have no anxieties about that they don't
have to go to the vaccination centers
uh they can either go to their gp
surgeries or indeed they will be visited
in their own home
now we go to julie elliott
thank you madam deputy speaker and can i
add my condolences to those already
expressed to the victims their families
and friends of this
awful illness one of the challenges
children and adults working from home
the town now time now for children
extended today by the prime minister
in addition to devices and connectivity
is a lack of digital skills
this week i was made aware of an online
scam
asking people to put their financial
internal information
into a fake a very plausible fake nhs
website
in order to get the vaccine what is the
prime minister doing to tackle this
criminal activity
preying on often vulnerable people
waiting for the vaccine
and also what is the prime minister
doing to ensure that individuals young
and old
have the digital skills they need to
protect themselves
learn from home and work from home
the honorable lady is absolutely right
about the importance of digital
skills and of connectivity
and that's why we're massively
increasing for instance giving a bit
broadband across the
uh across the country super fast
broadband uh and
making sure that people have the
technology that they need she raises a
particularly important point about
online scams
and they these are a a problem and
uh i can i can tell her that uh we're
working uh across
government to beat these uh fraudsters
uh
to root them out uh led by the the cabin
office and if she'd be kind enough to
send me details
of the case that she uh she mentions i
will feed it into our system immediately
and now we go to greg clarke
hi
do we have the sound working for mr
clark
apologize to the honorable
member that the system we appear to be
hearing the
sound engineers perhaps we
will leave that for a moment
we'll come back to the honorable member
for tonbridge wells
and meanwhile we'll go to york hopefully
to rachel maskel
thank you madam deputy speaker the
evidence shows that the government's
approach to easing the lock down before
christmas meant that crowds of people
came to york despite my warnings
spreading the infection in the retail
hospitality and transport sectors
because they could travel to a lower
tier and were off guard in my community
the result has been devastating it was
completely unsafe and completely
avoidable will the prime minister commit
not to return to a tiered system where
people can freely move the infection
from one place to another what steps
will it take to avoid this
catastrophe from happening again and can
i meet with one of his ministers
to discuss your tragic experience over
christmas
madam deputies because soon as we were
informed of the uh
extra transmissibility 50 to 70 percent
uh faster of
the new variant we took uh all the
action that we uh that we could
and i would just uh uh remind the
uh the honorable lady that uh the best
thing we can do
uh for the people of york now uh is to
to make sure that we keep this
virus under control uh and with the
measures that we are the tough measures
that we have
and that we uh all come forward uh for
the vaccine i
urge uh her to get her constituents to
come forward and take that vaccine they
do they're going great guns
in yorkshire i think uh it's my memory
as in yorkshire uh there i think they're
taking more vaccine than virtually
anywhere else
uh in the country and i congratulate the
people of yorkshire on what they're
doing
but we're now coming into the last
furlong of the jcbi
wonderful and it'd be great to get 100
of the people of yorkshire
uh in the course the next few days
now we go to my esteemed constituency
neighbor
robert halfon uh thank you madam deputy
speaker
in in all the gloom of the tragedy of
govid
will my wise model friend pay tribute to
the staff and volunteers working
so hard to scale up the programme of
vaccinations in harlow
and delivering the life-saving vaccine
to thousands of residents in our new
mass
vaccination center i know he wants
schools and colleges to open sooner
rather than later and i really
welcome what he has said today about
catch up the extra funding
free school meals and above all the
education plans work over recovery
will he ensure the catch-up fund also
helps children with mental health
problems
and will he work with the coalition of
the willing such as the children
commissioner and other educationalists
to get all our children back in the
classroom
yes indeed mr speaker i join my normal
offending congratulating
the volunteers not just the nhs the army
and
the pharmacies but the volunteers who
are making the vaccine roll out possible
and yes uh i can tell my right normal
friend that we do
uh we are putting extra funding into
mental health problems particularly for
uh for for children uh and young people
i think
and the funding that we've announced
every year of more than
2 billion extra 3 billion extra mr
speaker i think will go to
help 345 000 children
as well thank you and now we go to
judith cummings
you madam deputy speaker ons data shows
that key workers and those in manual and
public facing jobs are at the highest
risk
of dying from coronavirus radford is a
key worker city
and tragically over one thousand
bradfordians have now died from the
virus
when the most vulnerable groups have
been vaccinated will the prime minister
ensure that priorities then given to
front-line workers
who have played such a key role in
keeping the country going
during the pandemic often with a high
risk to their personal safety
including police officers teachers shop
workers
bus and taxi drivers and many others who
are just unable to work from home so
when will he publish
his plan to the next stage of the
vaccine rollout
can i just congratulate the honourable
lady for being so much more sensible
than her
party leader who is saying that he wants
to interrupt
the vaccine uh rollout for the
vulnerable groups
uh madam deputy speaker and and
decide politically to uh who should get
the vaccine
i think we should leave it to the joint
committee on vaccination and
immunization uh for the
for the jcvi uh to to do the
the the to decide the most vulnerable
groups that's what we're going to do
that's the fastest way to deal with
those who are most likely
to die i see she's shaking her head she
actually disagrees with the suggestion
uh that she's just made but i think that
it's an excellent suggestion that she
should stick to it
now we go to join morrissey
thank you madam deputy speaker and may i
thank the prime minister for his
commitment to reopen
schools as soon as possible and may i
also thank him for the vaccine
roll out but what i i'm asking today on
behalf
of children everywhere as a mother of a
nine-year-old i can see that children
young children are struggling and
their cognitive development is
determined at this age
we are storing up a lifetime of problems
of anxiety mental health
obesity by having all of our young
primary age children at home and please
may i urge
the prime minister to have courage in
these final months
to bring children particularly primary
age children back to school
as quickly as possible
my honorable friend is completely right
i know that she speaks for millions of
mothers and millions of parents
across the country who want our kids to
be back in school and who are anxious
about
the the gaps in their in their learning
that may be
arising as a result of this pandemic
we're going to do everything we can
to plug those gaps uh she's heard what
i've said about catch-up funds
about the investments that we're making
uh in in tuition and one-to-one
tutorials
uh but it will go on not just this year
but next year and
and throughout this parliament until
we've made up the ground for those kids
because
they deserve it and i will of course
work as fast as possible
to get schools open but we must do it in
a way that is cautious
and proportionate now we go to
allison thules
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
many people on low incomes and in
precarious work still cannot afford to
self-isolate on the uk's meager
level of statutory sick pay and some
aren't even entitled to that
so can i ask the prime minister what
impact does he feel the uk having one of
the lowest rates of such g6p
has had in the destiny and will he
increase it now as a matter of urgency
to help people do the right thing and
stay safe
madam deputy speaker in addition to
statutory sick pay and you know and
uh universal credit there is of course
also the 500 pounds
that we make available to those uh in
need of it
and uh that is the right way for when
i'm afraid she's not right in what she
says about the levels of statutory sick
pay
uh in this country they compare
favorably with countries around the
world
and now we go to peterborough
thank you madam deputy speaker
the government ordered the coving covid
vaccine
early they have delivered it efficiently
and we now have 11 of the population
vaccinated compare that with the
european union where because of their
bureaucracy inefficiency and petty
politics
they ordered the vaccine late
they delivered it inefficiently and have
only vaccinated
two percent of their population
prime minister it is not just a great
credit to your leadership and your
government
that we have delivered the vaccination
so quickly but also is it not
one of the great advantages of having
left
the european union
well mrs madame deputy speaker
i will i what i will say
uh is that the it's we certainly were
able to use
speed and agility to deliver on the the
program that we needed
to do and i think it would have been a
great pity madam deputy speaker if
uh we'd followed the advice of the
leader of the opposition
uh and the labour party who said stay in
the eu vaccines
uh program uh who want uh who wanted
uh and who wanted to to get rid of uh
big pharmaceutical
companies in the crazed corbynite agenda
on which the leader of the opposition
stood at the last election and who
attacked
the vaccine task force that secured 367
million
doses of a vaccine so mr speaker i do
think
that uh we've been able to do things
differently
and uh and better but uh
in some ways uh in some ways but
it is early days and it is very very
important
to remember that this is an
international
venture these vaccines uh we depend on
our friends
and partners and we will continue mr
speaker to work with
those friends and partners in the eu and
beyond
i didn't want to interrupt the
honourable member for
wellingborough while he was in full
virtual
rhetorical flow but he knows that he
mustn't
address the prime minister as you and he
mustn't say
what are you doing prime minister he
must address
the chair and he's setting a bad example
as a senior member
of this house as are many senior members
of this house
to new members who have yet to learn the
proper mode of address we must be
careful
during this time of virtual proceedings
not to let
standards fall we now go to
andrew guin thank you i support the
vaccination program my clinical
commissioning groups have been amongst
the best in england
at rolling out the covid vaccine a real
success story
for the communities i represent who've
been placed under restrictions since the
29th of july
but today the nhs has said it will cut
by one-third
the future vaccine supplies to the
north-west so the rest can catch up
that's worry and give true so can i ask
the prime minister about logistics
what impact does he think withholding
vaccines to the north west will have
will second jobs be delayed still
further or will the next cohort of first
jabs need to be rescheduled
leaving those people unprotected for
longer
um mr speaker i can confirm to the
honourable gentleman that
i will get make sure that his
constituents get
exactly what they need uh for the uh the
rollout to the to the one to four groups
i'm
sure by my uh honorable friend the
minister of vaccines there is no such
uh delay and i'm delighted that he now
supports
uh the vaccination perhaps he could
repudiate the
the policy on which he stood uh to
destroy the pharmaceutical companies
that have made them
uh possible and perhaps he could
dissociate himself from previous labor
attacks
on the vaccine task force uh that
secured the doses on which he now relies
are we now go to laura trott
thank you madam deputy speaker i welcome
the emphasis today on school return it
is
absolutely vital we know the devastating
impact that being out of school has on
children's mental health
the prime minister is absolutely right
schools are safe to return
there is now firm evidence that
particularly primary schools do not
contribute to the spread of this vicious
disease
will the prime minister commit to
sharing this evidence with teachers
parents and students so they can be
reassured that regardless of vaccine
schools are safe to return
the honourable lady is spot on schools
are safe
and the only issue with opening schools
as i said to the house earlier on
madam deputy speakers is of course that
they you add to the overall budget of of
transmission by opening them because you
bring
lots of households together obviously
that's what a school uh does
but schools are safe they're wonderful
places and uh we
i support my honorable friend in wanting
to get them open
as soon as possible now we go to
paul blomfield thank you madam deputy
speaker
i have self-employed constituents who
are coming up to a year without support
businesses in supply chains unable to
furlough staff
newly established businesses and others
who fall on foul of administrative
deadlines
as obviously do other members now i
welcome the support that has been
provided but will the prime minister
agree
to consider those who have fallen
through the gaps
and in answering can i ask him not to
repeat
the list of what has been done but to
say what he will do
now to support those excluded including
considering the cross-party proposal for
a targeted
income grant scheme
uh madam deputy speaker he makes uh uh
i'm an excellent point with one that's
been made many times across this house
and
we will of course do everything we can
to assist those who
are hard to uh identify and uh who don't
uh for hmrc purposes
are not easy to uh whose incomes and
who's
uh whose entitlements are not easy
therefore uh to calculate
uh the group is in fact far smaller than
uh you sometimes hear in this house
madame deputy speaking the cases can be
very complex
but we remain committed to doing
everything we can to help people
throughout the pandemic
and now we go to sir david amos
i join with my right honourable friend
in celebrating the success
of our vaccination program which is
working well in south
end i also welcome uh my right on board
friends remarks about
education however would he join me in
reminding people
that if they accept an invitation to be
vaccinated
they should keep that appointment and we
should all help
elderly people to do that otherwise
vaccinators will have to make the very
difficult decision at short notice
what to do with those spare vaccines
absolutely my right honourable friend
makes a very important point
uh we must get people uh to uh take up
their appointments and take up the
vaccines when they are
offered there are some uh some groups
who are proving tough to uh to reach
and i look forward to all all members
across the house working together
uh to uh encourage people in a positive
way
of the advent of the advantages of of a
vaccine it's a wonderful thing
go and get it if you get a message to do
so
and now we go to ian lavery
thank you uh modern deputy speaker
health life expectancy for men at birth
in the first world of my constituency of
one's back
is 52 years of age wise to
eight in them in the prime minister's
constituency
it's 71 years of age
and that trend looks to get only
that can the prime minister explain to
the people of my constituency why his
government is
so eager to avoid a vaccine poor school
lottery
by diverting our supply from the
northeast
southwards to more prosperous regions in
the country
simply because the nhs in our area have
done an
absolutely fantastic job whilst at the
same time
the government has done nothing to
tackle the poor school
lottery of healthy life expectancy
that varies so widely across this
country
and can i urge a prime minister to
consider where the cm actions
would have been taken if the shoe had
been
on the other foot before i asked the
prime minister to answer the question
i must beg for questions from members
i know that people are sitting at home
and the opportunity to make a speech
makes them want to speak for longer once
they actually have the attention of the
house
but please we will never get on to the
next statement or let the prime minister
go to um
to complete compete complete
all the promises he's made today if we
don't get this statement finished
prime minister uh well mr speaker i i
think the honourable gentleman and i
share an ambition we want to
to unite and level up and uh across the
whole of the uk that's the mission of
this
of this government uh and uh i
that's why i'm afraid he's totally wrong
what he says about the rollout of the
vaccines
uh we're making sure that everywhere
gets what they need
uh for the jcvi groups wonderful by
february the 15th that is what we are
doing and will continue to do but i'm
delighted by the way
uh by his conversion uh to the vaccines
i seem to have read somewhere
uh that he seemed a bit skeptical uh
madam deputy speaker
about uh there he goes uh smirking away
it's not a smirking matter
it's absolutely crucial tell your
constituents he should tell his
constituents man
that deputy speaker to get a vaccination
so desmond swain to lift lockdown will
he focus
exclusively on the vaccinate progress or
vaccinations of those who are most
likely to be hospitalized if infected
mission creep beyond hospitalizations
will inevitably lead to the diminution
of our sense of urgency
to lift the restrictions wouldn't it
my honorable friend is completely right
and he and he gets to the heart of the
problem
uh in the policy that's been announced
to the
pretend policy that's been announced by
the party opposite
because if you were a madam deputy
speaker to interfere
with the jcvi one to nine list which is
intended to target those most vulnerable
those most at risk of dying or
hospitalization you would of course uh
interpolate it with other people
appointed by politicians
and you would of course uh take vaccines
away
from the more vulnerable groups and as
as the honourable gentleman that rightly
says
you would delay our ability uh to move
forward out of lockdown he's spot on
and now we go to sarah owen
thank you madam deputy speaker like many
places
in luton we are challenged to produce
cases of covid as a large number of
people work in jobs
where it's not possible to work from
home what is the government doing to
support businesses to reduce workplace
transmission
will those plans include decent sick pay
and rolling out of home rapid test kits
to small and medium-sized employers to
support reducing this risk
she makes an excellent point about the
need to roll out uh
rapid test kits and that is happening uh
in
communities and towns cities across the
country and i commend her
for supporting them they are they may
not uh be
the total answer of course not to
fighting this disease but they're
extremely useful
in isolating asymptomatic cases uh and
uh and helping us to drive down the r
rate in local communities
bob stewart thank you so much madam
deputy speaker
could i ask my good and honorable friend
prime minister if priority lists
for vaccinations will be reviewed
after tiers one to four are complete
particularly for groups that we're
having
emails from such as police officers
supermarket cashiers teachers home
carers
and people with learning disabilities
some of whom seem to be
disproportionately afflicted by kovid
19. thank you of course he's right
to raise that and i thank my honorable
friend but
i just repeat what i said earlier to the
right honourable general leader of the
opposition
it follows from everything that i've
said that teachers in the vulnerable
groups
uh in those in that list of groups one
to nine
uh police officers in those groups
supermarket workers cashiers
uh in those in those groups people with
learning disabilities
they are our priority madam deputy
speaker they are our priority beats
because it's by vaccinating them
that will be able to reduce the i'm
afraid the tragic death toll
uh that we would otherwise see
now we go to dame diana johnson
thank you madam deputy speaker staff at
hall royal infirmary
and castle hill have been magnificent
during this pandemic
but they are used to making people
better and the death toll
on staff is taking its toll and they are
physically exhausted
so i wanted to know what the prime
minister is planning to do
to support exhausted staff in dealing
with the ever-growing waiting list
which they will face once the covid
threats has subsided
i thank her very much i think it was
simon stevens the
chief executive of nhs england who put
it best yesterday
when he said that the best thing we
could do for
our nhs staff and you know she's
absolutely right mrs
madame deputies you can what she says
about peop the the stress that
uh the nhs has been operating under
these last few weeks the pressure
that they're under the best thing we can
do now is to
keep this infection rate going down to
roll out
the the vaccination and indeed to make
sure that all nhs staff
are vaccinated which as she knows uh
they are in the jcvi
uh one to four group they are our prior
priority
for february the 15th greg smith
thank you madam deputy speaker the
rollout of the vaccine has been a truly
heroic effort by
absolutely everybody involved not least
to remain on track
to get the top four priority groups
their first dose by the middle of
february every vaccine
brings hope but there is also an
incredible amount of anxiety
in the country not least by business
owners unable to trade families juggling
home learning with holding down
jobs so can i urge my right honourable
friend as he looks at rightly lifting
the restrictions
to be really clear with all of our
constituents precisely what
when the data permits means so that
there can be absolute clarity as to what
needs to happen to lift each tier of the
restrictions
my honorable friend is absolutely right
and
i will of course be setting all this out
in the course of the next
few weeks but what i can tell the house
is that some obvious things that
the house can see for it for itself we
need to be uh sure that the vaccine
rollout continues to go at the pace with
the success that it currently is
we need to make sure that we're
targeting uh all those groups reducing
the the overall level of vulnerability
in the population uh we need to make
sure uh clearly
uh that the the vaccine is working
all the vaccines are working because uh
there are at least two now
uh in the sense that they are driving
down the mortality rate
of those elderly and vulnerable groups
we need to start to see that
uh madam deputy speaker the
promising signs from israel we haven't
yet seen
in this country the data that would help
us uh to be absolutely confident
of that point then of course of the
pressures on uh
the nhs and and other important
considerations to say nothing of the
very important economic uh
considerations that he also
raises but i can assure him that uh
there will be much more that will be
setting out in the course of the
of the next weeks to give reassurance
and uncertainty
as far as we can to all our constituents
now we go to lloyd russell
thank you madam deputy speaker when
australia had a second wave
they held an enquiry it showed the
failures of the private contractors in
the
um in the system of a quarantine that
they were running
they learned from it the minister
resigned and they are better
and now they are almost covered free the
prime minister is so right
in saying that of course every
government will make mistakes
but why won't the prime minister open an
inquiry now so we can learn those
mistakes and we don't keep repeating
them like delays in lockdown and delays
in school opening
and actually start to turn this thing
around
will he commit here and now to do a
short
sharp public inquiry as my committee
suggested
and so that we can all be the better for
it
i'm very grateful to the honorable
gentleman indeed to the work of his uh
of his committee and
uh i i know that uh those conclusions
along with many others will be studied
with
uh with care but i you i know you want
brief answers
um i really will direct him to the
answers i've i've already given uh to
here
to his right-hand friend the leader of
the opposition on that point and many
others
throughout the day of course we will
learn uh the lessons but at the height
of the pandemic uh we would have to
concentrate a huge amount of official
and health sector time uh to an inquiry
when we need to get on
with beating the virus now we go
to craig tracy
thank you madam deputy speaker and the
the role out the vaccine has been
an undoubted success for the government
but it brings us to a point where people
now want to understand the path ahead
to give them something to aim towards i
welcome the clarity
prime minister's given today on schools
but in the coming days can you also give
a clear route map
which sets out the potential for further
reason of receptions
such as when outdoor exercise facilities
such as golf courses can resume
hospitality events can restart now high
streets can re
open to reassure people that there is
light at the end of the tunnel
and they will shortly realize some of
the benefits for the incredible
sacrifices they've had to make
over recent months
my honorable friend is entirely right in
what he asks for and i will be supplying
i hope exactly that he will recall uh
last year
uh how we set out madam deputy speaker a
series of
uh of dates uh uh uh
by which uh the earliest we hoped to do
certain things he will recall july the
fourth i think for opening
uh hospitality and so on and so forth
uh i hope uh that in the course the next
few weeks we will be able to populate
the
uh the diary ahead uh with some more
milestones some more assumptions
about what we may be able to do that i
hope will give a reassurance to
uh to him to to businesses in his
constituency and to
to all of us and now we go to
marion fellows thank you madam deputy
speaker
the first minister of scotland has today
reinforced her message
telling people not to travel when it's
not really
really really essential and with new
border restrictions
it's likely we'll see a reduction in the
amount of travel
into the uk which will harm aviation
and travel firms is sector specific
support
coming in light of these new policies
prime minister
minister well mr madame of course we've
supported the aviation sector
uh throughout through the time to pay
scheme and and others and
uh we've just been introducing
particular support
for airfields runways that are not
in as much use as they as they could be
but the best way
as she knows to get that sector and all
others bouncing back
is to continue on the path that we're on
drive the virus down
vaccinate the population and open up
sensibly
and now we go to ian manns
very grateful madam deputy speaker
madame deputy speaker i should declare
an interest as as i am a chair of the
school governors
and trustee of a joint schools board
in my youth i was a scout and our motto
was be prepared and madame
deputy speaker i'd like to congratulate
school leaders and their staff for
keeping schools open
for vulnerable children and children of
key workers where possible
during the lockdown so could the prime
minister
get his right honourable friend the
secretary of state for education
to share his plan because he tells us he
has a plan
for the full reopening of schools with
school leaders as soon as possible
so that you'll be prepared to put into
place the necessary measures
to reopen schools fully and in such a
way that plans
have the confidence of parents children
and the school staff
that they would that their schools will
be ready and truly safe
for everyone i joined the honourable
gentleman very
much in congratulating schools on what
they've done to
to make their place their schools
covered secure the incredible amount of
work they're
they're doing it to educate i think 14
of kids are in school now
uh madam deputy speaker uh just to say
nothing of all the home
learning that is going on thanks to the
efforts of teachers
as well so thank you to uh to our
schools
and i've set out a little bit uh today
i think you'd agree madam deputy speaker
about what we plan to do to get schools
back the extra support that we're
uh we're giving uh the the timetable but
of course my ride on befriend the
secretary of state for education is
the gentleman suggests uh we'll be
saying more in due course
and now we go to rob butler
thank you very much indeed madam deputy
speaker the pubs the restaurants the
hairdressers the gyms and the many
excellent
shops of aylesbury are desperate to
reopen
can my right honourable friend reassure
them that the measures here has
announced today
combined with the vaccination rollout
will speed up when that will happen
and that there is a route out of
lockdown for us all
uh man deputy speaker i don't think i
could uh agree
more vehemently with uh my honourable
friend uh if i tried i don't think i
have nothing to add to his uh excellent
uh
question yes of course that is the way
ahead
and now we go to dama angela
eagle thank you very much
madam deputy speaker is the prime
minister proud that he spent half a
billion pounds of public money
on the eat out to help out scheme which
it
is now estimated increase the spread of
the virus by up to 17 percent
i wonder uh madam deputy speaker whether
the
right vulnerable lady is proud of
attacking the vaccine task force
uh for spending 675 000 pounds
on reach on whether vaccines would reach
the most vulnerable people
in our society
and now we go to dr jamie wallace
thank you madam deputy speaker will the
prime minister join me in thanking the
british military personnel who have
performed an incredible service in
helping to roll out the vaccine
at pace across every part of the uk
including
the 92 personnel helping in wales and
does he agree
that their service shows how the uk is
stronger when all
four of our nations work together in the
fight against this pandemic
madam deputy speaker it's been one of
the as i say one of the few
constellations of this
uh pandemic to see the way the country
has come together to fight it
and particular and particularly to see
the way great national institutions
great uk institutions such as the the
army uh british army have been
absolutely indispensable
uh in wales in scotland around the whole
of the uk
in in fighting uh this pandemic and i
know that uh it's appreciated across
the whole of the uk now we go to
jeff smith thank you madam deputy
speaker
in greater manchester there are 20 000
pupils out of schools and with no decent
access to online learning
can the prime minister assure me that
the 300 million pounds as he's just
announced in catch-up
and tutoring money will be targeted at
areas like greater manchester
where pupils have suffered
disproportionately because of
deprivation
because of high rates of infections that
cause multiple periods of isolation
keeping them off school
yes indeed madam deputy speaker he's
right to raise the problem of
differential
learning some some kids unquestionably
in some parts of the country uh some
families
have suffered more of a break in
their education than others there's
absolutely no doubt about it and that's
why
we're going to focus so much on the
catch-up funds that i've uh that i've
identified of course
greater manchester uh will be uh will be
uh
targeted uh for all the measures that
we've uh we've outlined this morning and
more to come
and now we go to
dean russell thank you madam deputy
speaker
um across watford we've got incredible
teachers and i would like to
ask the right one gentlemen my the prime
minister if he would agree with me
to thank them for the incredible work
they've been doing keeping schools open
for key work as children
and also confirm his priority to make
sure that schools can reopen
as soon as as is safe to do so in
line with our advice from our scientific
and medical advisors
thank you well my honorable friend and i
have visited wonderful schools in his uh
constituency together
uh we know uh the fantastic job that
they're doing and
i i know from talking to those teachers
and those pupils how much they
will be looking forward now uh to
getting back into uh to school i can
tell my humble friend we will do
everything we can
to speed it up we must be cautious we
must
make sure that we do it in in tandem
parry pass you
uh with the roll out of the vaccine
and now we go to barbara keely
thank you madam deputy speaker the prime
minister has talked about the important
support from the british army in the
vaccination rolo
and salford's program has been supported
by troops from the royal lanses
we do appreciate that but we've been
told that this military support is being
withdrawn next monday
giving less than a week to recruit and
train 30 people and that would mean
salford will be able to deliver 500
fewer vaccines a day delays to
vaccinations cost
lives so will the prime minister ensure
that this vital military support
isn't withdrawn from salford
um deputy speaker i i
very doubtful that uh the people of
sulphur would be deprived in the way
that she describes but i will of course
look into it urgently in my
honourable feminists for vaccines uh
will be look we'll be
taking it up immediately and
finally steve bryant
thank you uh many parents will have
faced homeschooling last year
with a sense of necessary resignation my
sense is that many are actually now
quite desperately worried about their
children
so it's just fantastic news that the
prime minister has said today that as
the vaccines roll out
the most vulnerable protected that will
move in lockstep and we'll get the
country back to school but can i ask him
whether the 8th of march date
has to wait for all the schools even
primary
given we all agree and he has said today
at the dispatch box that schools
are safe
i i i hear my uh honorable friend
loud and clear and i know he's i know
his views will be shared by many
uh in this house i just want to go back
to that
that that key thing that we need to to
establish and it won't alas be until the
middle of february
uh that we have real material evidence
uh that the vaccines are working in
terms of driving down
uh the mortality rate amongst those
crucial groups and so if you were to get
if you were to give
uh schools decent notice uh to come back
you're driven uh more towards the eighth
of uh of march
uh by that logic rather than uh rather
than coming back early i
i appreciate we've been round and round
believe me we've been round and round it
many times
madam deputy speaker this is a this is
about as fast as we think we can
prudently
go and i think that that is what the
country would want they would want
schools open
but they would want them open in a
cautious
and sensible way
thank you the prime minister boris
johnson has been making a statement
to the house of commons this lunchtime
two significant announcements from him
the first concerning schools
it will not be possible to open schools
immediately after the february half term
holiday the hope is to begin the
reopening of schools from monday
the 8th of march he said provided that
the vaccination program goes
as planned and that hospitalizations
begin to fall a plan for taking the
country
out of lockdown will be published by the
prime minister by the government
the week beginning the 22nd of february
and that will set out more detail on the
approach
for reopening of schools and on the
subject
of quarantine all arrivals from
high-risk countries will be required to
isolate
in government-provided accommodation for
10 days without
exception we're going to get more
details on that from the home secretary
pretty patel
shortly our chief political
correspondent john craig is in
westminster and was listening into that
statement
from the prime minister um he's been
under a lot of pressure
john to set out a road map for how
we come out of this period of lockdown
we've got
a little bit but not a lot
what we've learned is that uh pubs
restaurants
non-essential retail all of that that
staying
in england is staying shut until
probably some time after the 8th of
march because
yes the prime minister has announced
that date of the 8th of march
for the first school's reopening but it
sounded very much like a target
and what he didn't say of course was
that all those other things are going to
stay shut because he said
he's the phrase he's used before schools
being a national priority
reopening them a national priority and
it could be i mean over the weekend we
heard
um matt hancock the health secretary say
on sophie ridge on sunday
he hoped that schools would reopen at
easter well
march the 8th you're not that many weeks
from easter then and it could well be
easter before the schools open
and given that they're opening first
well that means everything else is
staying
shut now tory mps of course are
on on his case the coveted recovery
group led by mark harper
we heard from sir desmond swain during
the exchanges
talking about mission creep um the prime
minister clearly wanted to tell his
backbenchers look
as soon as we get back here after half
term we'll publish our proposals
but i can tell you our aim is to get
some schools back on the 8th of march
now he was uh very dismissive
both at pmq's and during that statement
of the calls from sir kia stammer to
test key workers like teachers and
police officers
mr johnson's argument is that that keeps
vaccination
sorry to vaccinate key workers that
keeps vaccinations away
from vulnerable people older people who
the government believes need them
more based on the advice from the
government scientists
however what mr johnson's saying about
that
slightly contradicts what mr hancock
also said on sophie ridge on sunday
that police officers could be in with a
shout he said
and yesterday at the combined hearing of
the health committee and the uh
the i'm gonna stop now because here's
pretty patel yeah thank you john
make a statement i'm deputy speaker i
would like to begin
my remarks by echoing the words of the
prime minister
the scale of the suffering this virus
has inflicted is truly
heartbreaking and my thoughts are with
those who have tragically lost loved
ones
yesterday madam deputy speaker when i
addressed the house i said the
government's focus
is on protecting the uk's world leading
vaccination program a program that we
should be proud of
and reducing the risk of a new strain of
the virus being transmitted
from someone coming into the uk
yesterday the foreign office
announced support for more countries to
access the uk's world-leading
gene sequencing capacities and
capabilities to increase
early identification of any new strains
of the virus
this is a vital step forward to support
the global response
to coronavirus but it is simply not
enough on its own
to reduce risk to the united kingdom
however madden deputy speaker it is
clear that there are still
too many people coming in and out of our
country each day
and today i am announcing further action
to strengthen
the health measures that we already have
at the border but to reduce
passenger flow so that only a small
number of people
for whom it is absolutely essential to
travel
are doing so and therefore reducing the
risk
to our world leading vaccine program so
for those entering the uk
there will be a number of measures
firstly the police have stepped up
checks and are carrying out more
physical checks at addresses to ensure
that people
are complying with the self-isolation
rules
second we will continue to refuse entry
to non-uk residents
from red list countries which are
already subject to the uk
travel ban third as the prime minister
has said
we will introduce a new managed
isolation process
in hotels for those who cannot be
refused entry
including those arriving home from
countries where we have already imposed
international travel bans they will be
required to isolate for 10 days
without exempt without exception
and the department of health and social
care will set out further details
on this approach next week and for those
traveling out of the uk
we will also be enhancing and stepping
up enforcement rules
because despite the stay at home
regulations madam deputy speaker we are
still seeing people
not complying with these rules the rules
are clear
people should be staying at home unless
they have a valid reason to leave
going on holiday is not a valid reason
so we will introduce a new requirement
so that people wishing to travel
must first make a declaration as to why
they need to travel
this reason for travel will be checked
by carriers
prior to departure and this approach
madame deputy speaker
effectively mirrors the checks on
arrivals that are already in place
with the passenger locator form secondly
working with policing partners
we will increase police presence at
ports and at airports
finding those in breach of the
stay-at-home regulations
anyone who does not have a valid reason
for travel will be directed to return
home
or they will face a fine third
we will urgently review the list of
travel exemptions
made to make sure that only the most
important and with exceptional reasons
are included these are crucial new
measures
to protect us all but also to complement
the robust action we have consistently
taken at the border
and while these new measures are being
operationalized i would just like to
remind
anyone seeking to enter our country to
comply
with the rules this includes providing
evidence of a negative covert test
before entering the united kingdom
self isolation on arrival for 10 days
and the completion of the passenger
locator form
immediately stepping up enforcement
means that if you do not follow the
regulations
you will face a fine madam deputy
speaker
these new measures at the border are a
necessary step to protect the public
and our world-class vaccination program
every layer of protection we have put in
place
will help to reduce the risk of
transmission of this virus
and any new potential strain from
entering the uk
and as we have done madame deputy
speaker throughout this global health
emergency
we will continue to take all steps
necessary to protect the public
and help prevent the spread of this
virus i commend the statement to the
house
nick thomas simmons thank you madam
deputy speaker
and i'm grateful to the home secretary
for her statement and for advanced sight
of it
we stand here today in knowledge of the
terrible fact that over a hundred
thousand people
have died as a result of this awful
virus we
mourn all of those lost and think of
those families
for whom life will never be the same
again
and in marking this it is not enough to
say
let us wait to find out why britain has
fared so badly
we must learn from past mistakes and
crucially
act now and one of the key areas where
the government has clearly fallen short
is on protecting our borders and i'm
deeply concerned
that the measures outlined today are yet
another example of this
too little too late yet again the
government is lurching from one crisis
to another
devoid of strategy and limiting hotel
quarantining
to only a limited number of countries
from which
travel from non-uk residents was already
banned
means that the home secretary's
proposals do not go anywhere near far
enough
and perhaps that's why it appears there
has been briefing to newspapers
that the home secretary is personally
not in support of the policy she's now
advocating
to the public mutations of the virus
risk undermining the efficacy of the
vaccines threatening life and hope we
cannot know where these mutations will
emerge from next
and the truth is the government is once
again behind the curve
labor is calling for a comprehensive
hotel quarantine
today's announcement is too limited it
leaves huge gaps in our defenses against
emerging strains
we know that the strains that emerged in
south africa and brazil have already
reached these shores
little wonder really when controls have
been so lacks
with just three in every 100 people
quarantining successfully contacted
and border testing only introduced 10
months
after our first lockdown and even then
the start had to be delayed
because the government couldn't get the
necessary systems in place
we've seen this reluctance to be
decisive from the start of the crisis
from the 1st of january to the 23rd of
march last year
only 273 people were formally
quarantined when over 18 million people
enter the country by air and this at the
time by the way when the government's
own chief scientific advisor said and i
quote
a lot of the cases in the uk didn't come
from china
they came from european imports and the
high level of travel
into the uk at the time in april i wrote
to the home secretary to ask her to
learn the lessons
but by may still the uk was an
international
outlier with no travel controls now as
the home secretary today belatedly
announces
very limited hotel quarantining many
questions remain which i would
appreciate if she could
address firstly how can we be assured
that travellers will not arrive with
emergent strains
via countries that are not on the
control list
second what support is being made
available
to ensure improvements to quarantine
compliance and the isolation assurance
service
and frankly why has it taken so long to
step
up checks as the home secretary said
today when we know the system's been
failing for months
what discussions have taken place with
hotel chains
to ensure the availability of rooms and
for those traveling
out of the united kingdom again why is
the enforcement
only being stepped up now and will the
home secretary ensure
that sufficient support and sufficient
resources are made available
for these very important tasks and when
madam deputy speaker will the government
announce a sector-specific support
package for aviation
getting this policy right is absolutely
crucial
the government cannot allow our border
policy
to continue to be the achilles heel
of the heroic efforts of the british
people during this pandemic
thank you madam deputy speaker i think
there are a number of comments that i
would just like to
make before i come to the honorable
gentleman's question
first of all i think it's first fair to
say that
compared to this time last year and i
was here yesterday madam deputy speaker
reeling off the endless measures at the
border that have been put in place since
january
last year including foreign office
advice statutory instruments
regulations and powers under the
coronavirus act and then of course
quarantine
passenger locator forms and test and
release as well as banning
flights and travel from specific
countries
i think it's important to recognize that
because of the
incredible work that we have in this
country
with regards to the vaccine our world
leading vaccine program
we're in a very different situation now
last year because of the additional risk
to public health caused by new variants
and it's this new variant obviously that
we should be focused on
um because obviously that could be less
susceptible it could have implications
for the vaccine
so it is important that we reduce risk
by reducing the number of people who
enter our country and could be a new
threat obviously in terms of the
variance
the variance mutations we've already
implemented
numerous measures and um protections to
reduce that risk
but these are a number of new additional
levels of protection
at our disposal that are being announced
today but also
forthcoming with regards to hotels and
i'm going to come on to the specifics in
a minute
um the honorable gentleman has also made
the point
about travel now the fact of the matter
is
there are reductions in travel already
and the number of people that are
traveling has reduced by 90
obviously compared to this time last
year but obviously that number will
become lower through various travel
bans that have been put in place he's
touched on
enforcement measures and the ias service
and also police enforcement there are a
number of new measures
or enhanced measures i should say that
will increase
the checks that will take place so is
service for example from tomorrow
will be checking over 5 000 people
is also contact those who arrive and way
in which they have been 10 days prior
in the way in which they are naturally
asked to do so with regards to
self-isolation
but of course police presence i've
spoken today about enhanced police
presence at ports and at borders
and at airports there will be an
increase of around a thousand
targeted follow-up visits a day and this
at a time when the numbers are reducing
speaks about the stringency of these
measures and that speaks to the point
about giving assurance around these
particular
enforcement measures i think it is
disappointing madam deputy speaker the
honorable gentleman
naturally being critical of government
measures
i said yesterday i've said on a number
of occasions i'll say it again
today from january last year we have had
a led approach to our measures at the
border
this is clearly about through the travel
ban
having a ban on travel from countries
that pose a risk high-risk countries
and there are measures in place that
i've outlined with building upon those
but i think for his party in particular
to claim that they've been calling for
tougher restrictions
since the start of this pandemic is
absolute nonsense because it's simply
not the case
um they themselves have been
flip-flopping as i said yesterday again
in terms of calling quarantine a blunt
tool a blunt instrument
um shadow transport secretary saying
that quantity measures should be
lessened
um this there is inconsistency clearly
in the position of the party opposite
and we have always taken an approach to
manage risk
on the point that he makes with regards
to
support packages there's work taking
place across government there's other
government departments but we're working
together on that
in terms of discussions with hotel
chains those discussions naturally are
underway
um that's not for me right now to talk
about those discussions but there's a
lot of work
a lot of work taking place and i think
again it's important madam deputy
speaker to recognize
that these measures and all measures
have logistical and operational
implications as well as challenges
we will work through those
practicalities with all our stakeholders
all our partners
my colleagues in government will come to
the house as the honorable gentleman
would expect
to provide the updates whether it's on
hotels whether it's on sectoral packages
the dialogues that are taking place and
i would just finally like to say madame
deputy speaker
i think the british public absolutely
recognized that this is a deeply deeply
challenging period
for our country no one will dispute that
these are difficult times throughout
this global pandemic
but there is no simple or single binary
approach that can be taken
it is right that we manage risk it is
right that we do so
in this layered approach but also i
think the british public our
constituents in particular madam deputy
speaker
they'd like to see all political parties
come together
at this important time to look at how we
can bring in these measures and support
these measures so that we can protect
public health
hugh merriman thank you very much madam
deputy speaker
can i thank the home secretary for her
statement i very much welcome the
evidence and nuance based approach that
the home secretary
has outlined today as opposed to
a blanket approach that seems to be
advocated by
her shadow which i believe would lead to
impacts on trade
and those that do need a central
business our ability to actually hotel
quarantine so many people and
i know that he takes seriously um the
need of the aviation industry i don't
believe a blanket approach would do
anything
for that so i welcome the government's
approach can i ask the home secretary
this
um knowing that some countries may be
added on
and indeed some countries may be taken
off uh the list where hotel quarantine
is required will that criteria be
published
and also will it be subject to both
further scrutiny
and perhaps votes from this place
thank you because there's some important
points and he's absolutely right i stood
here
yesterday madame versus you speak with
the dispatch box speaking about the
importance of freight
and the work the government has done
over recent months in fact at christmas
and run up to christmas to keep freight
moving
um despite various closures of borders
that took place which completely make
the honourable gentleman's point
that you simply cannot have that viable
approach there are logistical and
operational challenges
um and clearly government is working
through many of these
he makes some important points obviously
about changes
changes to guidance changes to advice
across governments so from the
department of health to the department
of transport to the fcdo
who play a very important role here as
well in terms of public communications
and assurance to the public
around countries and changes that take
place
clearly government will publish that
government will come to the house for
the commons
to share that information i would just
like to conclude
my comments though madam deputy speaker
by saying though
the current guidance is clear that
people should be staying at home unless
they've got really exceptional reasons
um to travel and of course going on
holiday is not a justifiable excuse or
reason
now we go to the spokesman for the snp
joanna cherry thank you madam deputy
speaker and i'd like to thank the home
secretary
for her statement and for advanced sight
of it
my scottish government colleagues are
concerned as she knows that her
proposals don't go far enough
and i would be grateful if she would
confirm that she will listen to their
representations
it is of course her department's
responsibility to control the united
kingdom's external borders
her department holds the passenger data
and the uk
border force report to her so it's right
that the home secretary should be the
one to address the risks raised by
transmission of the virus by arrivals
from
abroad so i'm going to repeat the
questions i asked yesterday during the
urgent
question on this same topic and which
the home secretary did not
answer at that time i hope that having
had 24 hours notice to think about my
questions and to discuss them with her
colleagues and advisors
she will now answer them in april and
may of last year i wrote to her asking
for comprehensive health protections at
the uk's external borders
and i referred to the measures that were
being introduced in other countries in
europe and across the world
other honourable members in the home
affairs committee were making similar
requests backed up by evidence
last week the home secretary admitted
that we were right
and she said that she thought the united
kingdom should have closed its borders
earlier so can she now tell me
why she failed to take the precautions
that she knew were needed at the start
of the pandemic
what stopped her from closing the
borders
was it her cabinet colleagues and if so
why did she not resign and speak out
given the risk of increased risk of
transmission from people entering the
country
and finally have the government
commissioned an assessment of what
contribution the failure to close the
borders
earlier has made to the dreadful death
toll across the united kingdom
and will she put the results in the
public domain
these are questions which concern not
just my constituents and those of my snp
colleagues but they concern people
across the four nations
so will she please answer them thank you
thank you madam deputy speaker um well
first of all
um i will repeat very much what i said
yesterday about working with all the
devolved administrations and clearly the
government is doing that and the
honourable lady russian lady will be
well aware of that
with regards to um everyone now going
retrospective in terms of thinking that
they were first advocates of
bringing in health measures at the
border clearly that was not the case
and i recall this from the select
committee last april and i mentioned
that yesterday as well
and if i can reacquaint the right
honourable lady with the measures that
had been brought in from
january 2020 from the minutes
of self-isolation advice that was given
from the fco at the time
from sage recommendations around
self-isolation for
specific countries from the 10th of
february to the new regulations and
statutory instruments that were brought
in new powers for medical professionals
and the police to detain
individuals suspected of symptoms of
covid
to the guidance to uk airports to
the travel advice that was put out from
the fcdo all between
february and march a self-isolation
measures introduced with specific
countries
introducing mandatory quarantine the
passenger locator form as well back in
june
last year to close in the border to
denmark
with the first identification of a new
strain which of course we were able to
deal with because of our genomic
sequencing
um capacity in the uk from test and
release to banning flights from south
africa
which clearly is still in place to carry
a liability for pre-travel
testing and pre-travel tests these
measures each of these measures madam
deputy speaker
we have introduced have added another
layer of protection against transmission
of the virus
and that reduces the risk of new
dangerous strains being imported into
the uk and i think the honourable lady
should also rush on board ladies should
reflect upon the fact that there is not
a single measure that mitigates risk
entirely
every measure that has been brought in
helps to reduce risk
helps protect the vaccine and
importantly helps to protect the british
public and public health
so graham brady speaker thank you i
agree with the chairman of the select
committee with
a million british jobs dependent on
aviation and much of british commerce as
well the government must be right
to be taking an evidence-based approach
not a blanket approach
whilst we all hope that we will discover
that the new variants are combat
adjusted effectively by the
vaccines as the existing variants in
this country
if it were to be the case that new
countries needed to be added to the red
list
will she speak urgently to our right
honourable friend the chancellor
about the support that will be needed by
our aviation sector to prevent a massive
hemorrhaging of jobs and prospects
across much of the country
thank you madam chip speaking my russian
friend is absolutely right and um
speaking of the sector and he's a
powerful advocate for the sector as well
um and i know of his constituency
interest with manchester airport group
um and the work that he's conducted with
them as well there is no question madam
deputy speakers i said jessica
emphasize this again that the sector are
they are our partners they are the
operational partners who we work with
every single day my colleagues in border
force for example
but specifically in terms of new
additional
lists or travel bans basically to
specific countries
that work is always under review and
alongside that
we continue to work with our operational
partners we discuss with them obviously
the implications of this those
discussions will always continue and
government will always step up
in whichever way it can to provide the
necessary support needed
now we go to chairman of the select
committee yvette cooper
thank you madam deputy speaker i welcome
these measures but they don't go far
enough to deliver a comprehensive
system the we know the brazil and south
africa variant have already been
identified across several continents and
in the
first wave less than one percent of new
cases came from china
the overwhelming majority from european
countries the government said were low
risk
at that time so can i ask the home
secretary about the number of people
likely to still be arriving who are not
covered by quarantine hotels
still won't have to do further tests on
arrival and will be able to go straight
onto the public transport system from
heathrow or wherever they arrive
can she confirm is that likely to still
be thousands of people each day
and does she think that is wise
came out of deputy speaker um i thank
you right honorable lady for her
question
i think first of all it's important that
i come back to this point that
all the measures every measure that has
been introduced across government
um has provided degrees of protection
various layers
and levels of protection against
transmission of the virus
the right honourable lady has heard me
say already
that travel is down from 90 compared to
this time
last year um clearly there are travel
bans in place
for countries that are redlisted and
that'll continue
and the announcement today will also
reduce the number of traveling
passengers i do want to emphasize that
because people should simply not be
traveling and we see the examples madame
deputy speaker i've got i will call some
of them out i mean border force have
given me examples
where even at some pancreas people have
been turning up with their skis
um that is clearly not acceptable we see
plenty of influences on social media
showing off about which parts of the
world that they are
in mainly in sunny parts of the world
going on holiday is not
is not um is not an exemption and it's
important that people stay at home
um i would just like to say of course
that with regards to the measures
um that are being announced today and
also with regards to quarantine
in the hotel um measures and package in
particular
um the hotel package that's under
discussion right now clearly
um in terms of the application of that
and the administration of that and the
right honorable lady speaks about people
getting on public transport we want to
absolutely
reduce the risk of people traveling in
that way
and therefore these are measures that
governments are working through right
now
in terms of how people can travel to
hotels how they will quarantine and i've
already spoken
about the checks that will also be put
in place on individuals when it comes to
self-isolation
richard holden thank you very much
madame deputy speaker and i'd like to
thank the home secretary for a statement
uh marjorie from crook got in with me uh
get in touch with me today
like many of my north west durham
constituents marjorie is fed up of labor
playing politics with coronavirus the
shadow of home secretary
himself has criticized our border
measures before as a blunt tool
today he's saying they don't go far
enough it's like some twisted version
of goldilocks where the government's
solution is never just
right does my right honourable friend
agree with margery that it's
irresponsible to play politics with
chronovirus
and will she also ensure that if these
measures need to be extended further to
other countries
they'll be done so at the earliest
opportunity
a friend is absolutely right and i agree
with everything he says about the party
opposite in terms of their flip-flopping
but also their
claims and i would just like to praise
marjorie as well
for you know the points that she has
made i think she speaks
for the british public who are fed up
with
party politics being played at this
critical time madam deputy speaker
when the public want to see unity rather
than the type of
um gripes that we are seeing and hearing
or the approach of armchair generals in
particular but he asked an important
question
about you know rolling out further
travel bans to other countries
the government will absolutely not
hesitate if there are new strains
emerging from other countries the
government will take action which is
exactly what margery and the british
public would expect
now we go to aleister carmichael
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
and can i thank the home secretary for
advanced site for statement
many of those that will be caught by
these new measures
will be traveling as a result of family
bereavement
and will already have incurred
substantial cost very often
at short notice so can the home sector
tell me if there will be some sort of
financial assistance available
for people of modest means who find
themselves in this position
at that most difficult of times
well my rational friend is the russian
board gentleman is absolutely right in
terms of highlighting
the exceptional examples and the sad
examples
that you know circumstances for people
to travel bereavement being a terrible
terrible
case um the government is already in
discussions with regards to exemptions
and support packages and things of that
nature
i'm unable madam deputy speaker to
confirm the details right now because
this work is underway
but you know it's a matter of time
before my colleagues will obviously
notify the house
and share further information on this
now we go to sir david amos
i very much support and welcome my right
honourable friends announcements of
restrictions at our borders
as a result of the current health crisis
would she reassure me
that regional airports such as south end
will be tasked to strictly enforce these
rules
as a number of local residents have
expressed
concerns that coronavirus infections may
be transmitted
by rivals through the airport
thank you madam deputy speaker my right
honourable friend
um is absolutely right um and i can
understand why he's raising
um the the the um importance of regional
airports um
throughout this pandemic they have
played an important role um all airport
operators take responsibility
for the way in which they work with us
but also for enforcing
coronavirus measures and restrictions so
that social distance in and keeping
passengers apart
particularly as they go up to pcps and
obviously
um then come across border force
officers it is
absolutely right that airports who who
are our operational partners work
with us to take responsibility that
shared responsibilities i've spoken
about so frequently
in terms of checking with the carriers
that the carriers and the
passenger locator form is completed but
also
ensuring that they themselves put those
protective measures in place to stop the
spread of this virus
now we go to rachel hopkins
thank you madam deputy speaker i'm very
concerned about the continued threat of
kovid19 to frontline border force staff
at heathrow
as the new draconian fixed team working
rosters have been
have made social distinct distancing
difficult at the same time as covered
transmission rates have been at their
highest so
can the home secretary confirm reports
that covert secure bubbles have
repeatedly been breached
due to understaffing and the new fixed
rosters
and specifically outline what assessment
she's made of the adequacy of
all border force staff's working
conditions
thank you very much lady for a question
um and it is an important question in
terms of board for staff
four or four staff are on the front line
day in day out trying to protect
the public from the spread of this virus
and they are doing exceptional work and
yesterday i thank them for the work that
they are doing
um in terms of measures that are in
place to protect them i'm
absolutely focused on protecting our
border force staff it's absolutely right
that that takes place
um the head of border force my
colleagues across the border force team
have been working assiduously with all
border force colleagues
particularly at heathrow airport because
heathrow airport is a busy airport
as we saw on saturday night where queues
did form because obviously
um we are enforcing 100 compliance
checks
and with that of course i come back to
my point working with
heathrow airport limited in terms of the
measures that they are putting in place
for social distancing
keeping passengers distant from border
force staff and of course ensuring that
our staff my staff are protected that is
my number one priority
now we go to sir robert neil
thank you madam deputy speaker i i
support the proportionate approach that
my right honourable friend has adopted
but can she help you in relation to two
linked matters
uh she said that she'll be looking
urgently the exceptions
will she particularly bear in mind the
need
to make provision for those who may be
repatriated
for urgent medical treatment and should
the extension we hope it does not at any
time
involve any british overseas territory
would she bear in mind the need for
early consultation with them we hope it
never comes to it
but again we have medical and other
obligations in some cases to them
my right honourable friend madam deputy
speaker is absolutely right
the case of medical exam exemptions and
urgencies
have always been um on the exemption
list and the exemption this is under
review right now colleagues across
government across all government
departments are reviewing the exemption
list
and when changes are made they will be
publicized through the usual channels
and of course anything that would affect
overseas territories will also be under
consideration and
that'll also be put in the public domain
and now we go to kevin brennan
thank you madam deputy speaker i
listened very carefully to the home
secretary's answer to the chair of the
select committee earlier and she didn't
answer a rather direct and important
question which she will have estimates
for
because this will be a policy based on
evidence
how many people does she expect each day
to have to go into quarantine in a hotel
and how many people entering the uk each
day
does she estimate will not have to go
into quarantine
under these new measures thank you madam
deputy speaker well management
i think first of all it's important to
recognize we do have
numbers in terms of the number of people
coming through our border
every single day these new measures
though and i think it's important to put
this into context
these new measures will bring those
numbers even further down
so we still have a lot of british
nationals that are traveling um and
clearly
the advice is and the guidance is clear
people should not be trapping they
should be staying at home
and through the enforcement measures
that will reduce dramatically
and the government is already working
out capacity in terms of hotel
accommodation
and also the night of the period of
self-isolation
that will be required and government
will happily share those figures
with colleagues in due course
now we go to steve double
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
it is absolutely
right that the government take
necessarily appropriate steps to keep
our country safe
from these new variants of the virus
that are emerging
around the world and i welcome the home
secretary statement
but she will know that any additional
restrictions on travel will further
damage the aviation sector
that has been deeply impacted by this
pandemic
when businesses in other sectors have
been forced to close or unable to trade
because of restrictions
specific financial support has been made
available so can i ask the home
secretary
if she will talk to the secretary for
secretary of state for transport and the
chancellor
to see what specific support can now be
provided
for airlines and airports to ensure that
they are in
a position to help lead our recovery in
the future
thank you madam deputy speaker i'd like
to give my honorable friend
every assurance that we are working
together across
transport the treasury the foreign
office with regards to the
aviation and the travel sector um
conversations and discussions are
underway
as i said earlier on madam deputy
speaker they are our operational
partners
um we work collectively with them so
those discussions are underway and i
just like to give them that assurance
and now we go to steve mccain
how will the quarantine hotels be
selected and will the home secretary
set a limit on how far such a hotel
can be from the arrival airport
so as to minimize risks during
transfers for which i assume she will
also be responsible
speaker madam deputy speaker with
regards to
hotels and measures as i've indicated
already that work is underway in terms
of
um looking at procurement of hotels who
the partners are going to be
but also further information around them
so
government will be setting out over the
next few days
the coming days further information with
regards to hotels and the processes
around them
that work as i indicated earlier on um
there are logistical
and operational aspects that we are in
discussions
underway right now and so my colleagues
will come back to the house and provide
that information
now we go to deanna davison
thank you madam deputy speaker and i
thank the home secretary for her
statement
protecting the british people quite
rightly has to be our priority and so
it is right that our border measures
have been under constant review since
the pandemic began
but in light of today's announcement can
my right honourable friend confirm that
our border force
and other frontline emergency workers
will be given all the support
they need to enforce these rules so that
they can keep themselves and the british
public safe
friend is absolutely right border force
are doing incredible work
on the front line and i'm i'm assuming
that and
getting reports of that every single day
and it's important that they stay safe
which is why we have strong measures in
place for them
but alongside that clearly enforcement
whether it's through policing the iis
service
all of that has absolutely been
accelerated along with the checks
the fact of the matter is we do have
clear checks passenger locator form must
be completed
there are fines for non-compliance
there's a requirement for self-isolation
for arrivals
these measures and these checks are in
place and they will be
increased clearly to protect public
health
[Applause]
and now we go to stephen bonner
thank you madam deputy speaker it has
been widely reported that the home
secretary called for
tougher sanctions at the border than
these somewhat reduced measures she is
announcing here today
has she been overruled and undermined
thank you madam deputy speaker um as i
reiterate madame deputy speaker first of
all i'd refer the gentleman to my
statement and the measures that have
been announced
it's important to recognize every single
measure that has been put in place
including a ban on international travel
um for
high-risk countries they are in place to
protect the british public
and these measures along with all the
other measures announced today are part
of this
layer of protection to reduce
transmission of the virus
and reduce new risks of a new dangerous
variant coming into the united kingdom
and now we go to
oh i wasn't expecting to go to
that do we not have the home secretary
pretty patel they're making a statement
on quarantine for arrivals in
to the uk she said the police would be
stepping up checks for
self-isolation those traveling from
redless countries who cannot be
refused entry i.e uk residents will have
to isolate in government accommodation
for 10 days
with no exceptions anyone wishing to
travel
must fill in a declaration form as to
why they need to
going on holiday she said is not a valid
reason and anyone without a valid reason
will be sent home or issued with a
fine our chief political correspondent
john craig
is in westminster there has been much
debate over
the last couple of weeks about how far
this quarantine should
extend it's a fairly limited
announcement we've had today john
clearly there's been a split amongst the
top levels of the cabinet uh with
those uh i mean we know that pretty
patel has been telling people she wanted
a blanket ban
she said so in uh talk to some
conservative
activists this was raised actually by
nick thomas simmons in the exchanges
just now
yes it's just uh travel from hotspots
what's quite tough and uh
is new is the fact that you're going to
have to fill in a form and say
why you're traveling and there was quite
a colorful anecdote from pretty patel
in answer to one mp's questions she said
there have been stories of people
turning up at some pancras
with skis to go on skiing holidays um
so she was talking about uh going on
holiday is not an essential uh
uh not essential travel uh now
it's been quite a clash between pretty
patel
and labour's nick thomas simmons the
shadow home secretary
she's accused him of playing politics
she's claimed labourer armchair
generals and he in return has said that
the borders
risk being the achilles heel in the
fight against kovid
while all this has been happening up in
scotland
nicolas sturgeon has been hitting out on
the subject of essential travel
on reports that the prime minister is
due to travel to scotland later this
week
she says i'd me traveling to it from
edinburgh to aberdeen to visit a vaccine
center is not essential
boris johnson traveling from london to
wherever in scotland
to do the same is not essential if we're
asking other people to abide by that i'm
sorry it's incumbent on us to do
likewise
i think we're going to hear a bit more
about that row over the next
24 hours or so if the prime minister is
planning a visit to scotland
but clearly in the house of commons she
has confirmed
uh what uh many of us have been
expecting that there is
going to be um this ban on people coming
in
from the quarantine plan for people
coming in
from overseas but it is only hotspot
countries
it's not a blanket ban and uh the
government's opponents are saying
she's not going far enough but we know
that she's advocated inside the cabinet
for tougher rules
clear clearly she appears to be
overruled by the prime minister and the
chancellor
and john prior to the home secretary we
heard from the prime minister himself
with an announcement on schools
well uh he began actually by stealing uh
the the home secretary's announcement
about travel restrictions but yes
uh the prime minister had uh in his news
conference last night he said he was
going to
provide some sort of route out of the
lockdown well what we had today
was a bit of a timetable from the prime
minister so
no end to current restrictions in
england prior to school half term
uh there will be a review during half
term uh the government will come back to
the commons when
mps are back immediately after half term
so that's
probably the will be the week beginning
the 22nd of february
but what he did announce was that
schools will be the first thing to
reopen
if it's considered safe for them to do
so and they will not that will begin
the eighth of uh march now it sounds
very much like a target
and of course it also means there'll be
no restrictions if schools are first
it means there are no reopening of pubs
restaurants and non-essential retail
and so on until uh probably sometime
after march the eighth this was the
prime minister making his announcement
about that march the eighth day if we
achieve our target
of vaccinating everyone in the foremost
vulnerable groups with their first
dose by the 15th of february and
every passing day sees more progress
towards that goal
then those groups that have developed
immunity from the virus
about three weeks later that is by
the 8th of march
we hope it will therefore be safe to
begin the reopening of schools
from monday the 8th of march
so um mr johnson has been insisting
today that schools are safe
uh he's been reminded by sir kia starmer
that he talked
called them vectors for transmission
back in january
i must say one of the uh features of
today's
two statements and indeed prime
minister's questions
is uh that the prime minister has been
much more combative
yesterday we saw last night at the news
conference a very somber tone
from the prime minister as he marked
that uh ma tragic milestone of a hundred
thousand
coveted deaths in the uk um saying how
sorry he was
and uh also uh uh that he believed he'd
done all he could today he really took
the fight to serkia stammer
at prime minister's questions and in the
statement uh this afternoon
and we've seen quite a bit of that from
pretty patel as well so
after a somber tone yesterday
government's uh
pleasing its own backbenchers with the
dates of when some of the restrictions
may be changed
and when schools might start to go back
uh but
a bit of a real clash between the prime
minister and the leader of the
opposition
and